[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec mais qui est le plateau mais qu'ils
sont en bonne santé avant j'aimerais
qu'on accueille les invités hier jean
salençon et d'abris
à l'arrivée le destin de france dans
affaire conclue puisque ont plané de la
machine
je sais pas s'il va l'atc ce soir parce
qu'à mon avis ça va ça va me servir
non non non non mathieu est là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
mozilla vous connaissez dylan on l'a vu
dans koh lanta on l'a vu dans les médias
ou ailleurs on l'a vu en apparence on
l'a vu en fait partout en fait il fait
chaud il fait beau on l'a vu partout
alors je vous explique le principe de
7,9 machinerie qu elle va consister
calmez-vous matthieu delormeau
l'élection c'est une grosse émission
bibi sont aujourd'hui comme avait bouclé
cela on va s'intéresser aux émissions de
dating est ce que c'est bidonné ou pas
failli et beaucoup de choses donc assez
concentré bonjour on va donc tester
cette machine la casta love machine
alors il ya des casques qui sont là et
la machine va tirer au sort deux
personnes une fille qui vont danser
ensemble pour être alors on peut faire
garçon garçon c'est là l'intérêt oui
mais voilà mais c'est la machine devait
décider dans un premier coup à temps
égal alors
[Applaudissements]
alors elle est alors c'est pas tous là
mais non là c'est le verras tu risque
plus rien alors tout est fait avec moi
tout est propre
voilà attention attention notre système
est rodé c'est à dire qu'ils allaient
faire un lifting
alors c'est qu'on prenne à cette machine
je les tester sur rue non c'est pas
grave ça j'en vois pas aller à bath et
donc mettez vous mettez vos sensations
mais c'est une blague non mais à les
connecter fait gaffe en tout cas déjà
visuellement le couple est beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention voilà
[Applaudissements]
destiné
oui
[Applaudissements]
démantèlement
sont plus qu'à un fil et de sardines
créé c'est à dire que c'est à dire que
alors alors alors on est on est à en
état on est à 2 % dire que sauf que max
ouais 2%
maxime gay ni même avec une chaîne je
pense quand même si vous dites vous des
mails et surfer c'est évidemment ils ont
essayé d'aider mais démêler le vrai du
faux
brossac olalalala il me tutoie prochain
couple allait attention on y va ah non
voilà ton bébé en charge alors allez-y
cette machine est totalement totalement
guider par le hasard comme ça et puisque
l'allemand contrôlé par la réussir à
passer truc là il serait bon ensemble
c'est dommage
et cette année les oreilles
le service
pourquoi moi
alors si m
[Musique]
alors quoi
[Applaudissements]
j'invite un homme
les uns parce que j'avais santé une
érection
m qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour qu'on
atteigne les 100 % ça je pense que les
différences c'est vrai c'est quand vous
coucher avec quelqu'un il ya une chimie
ou pas qui se fait à pau et tout ça on
sait jamais c'est après avoir couché que
je vous le dirai à bâle lundi bien
quatre ans
quel est le secret de son sex-appeal tué
alors on va maintenant tester un autre
coupe ou à machine alors là je vais
choisir parce que on va accélérer daniel
daniel daniel moreau et benoît
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
savoir
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ceci en première main nettement daniel
avec une moustache on aurait monté plus
noir sa masse avec eux ses rimes confié
de mission pour aujourd'hui on voudrait
quand même qu'il se passe quelque chose
pour vous dans votre vie lerhe
sentimentalement parlant et donc on a
une surprise vous allez vous mettre un
petit va vous mettre vous allez vous
mettre un sou pour bander les yeux vous
ne bougez pas à broadway en fait c'est
ça en français on appelle ça un bandeau
alors il reste une seconde comme le sait
qu on a toujours eu des doutes sur vous
est ce que voulait faire avec moi ça
m'est avis quelqu'un de bouger bouger
pas de moi j'aime à vous les pensez que
j'aurais pensé après je garde ça en en
cas pour tout à l'heure tu pas pressé
non plus alors je vois vraiment bas ok
oui rien donc je vais vous mettre le
casque sur la tête le alors voilà et on
a une surprise pour vous c'est quelqu'un
qui est là parmi deux reprises c'est
souvent quelqu'un qui est là par niveau
là on va vous faire entrer quoi ça vous
fait rentrer la surprise sur scène
évidemment
alors alors oiseaux
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la trame est élevé et les biens
[Rires]
des beaux jours
non mais pas de bordeaux daniel monzon
attention quelle est la compatibilité
amoureuse
alors attention attention les voilà
arrivés et ont enlevé sa sale blanc doit
normalement d'opio la main que tu va
pêcher ce soir on avait pas ma perruque
voilà merci
une rose jaune baiser vous [ __ ] tout
ma séquence donc cette personne vous est
compatible à 99%
c'est à dire qu'il ne manque rien pour
qu'on arrive à à toute chose je crois
que santé matin la jalousie 1 c'est la
came c'est vous dire c'est vous dire
l'âge de monsieur alors je plaisante ans
alors est ce que vous voulez voir quelle
est cette personne
ah bah oui de gestion attention un petit
truc un petit truc attention mais pas
deux trois bras a bon dos
[Applaudissements]
et en plus les seuls à 99%
il avait offert la même taille également
alors toi comme dirait mon compte et
dire qu'on gagne pour gagner ce petit
pour cent qui nous manque c'est rien
pour cent noms qui nous séparent de pur
bonheur
je sais pas du bonheur avait cependant
je crois que vous avez préparé quelque
chose
frédéric pour retourner morrow qui jeu
qui jauge de vous le dire
à 13 ans je négocie sur ces mondiaux sur
une autre lauda la rose une rose jaune
m'a parlé ça parle couleurs pour secret
a poussé là sur mon piano d'abord à
blondeau d'heure pour mentaux les fleurs
elle aime la musique la chine
les fleurs comprennent les fleurs
s'expliquer leur fraîcheur leur
arrogance donne de la couleur au slam un
kit accueillis dans quelques jardins au
pays ou à la rose couleur de peau et toi
messagère démo vient te chercher et va
porter à l'âme que j'ai choisi d'aimer
ce baiser d'ivresse confuse dans ce
silence comme une intruse car cette
route couleurs de nous aurait pas d'où
les nombreux sous ma plume
vivante entre ciel et piano ont les yeux
de daniel moreau
[Applaudissements]
les
on voit maintenant intéressé
je crois pour vous qu'il est votre
couple qu'est ce qui se passe entre j'ai
un petit 4 1 comme ça qui me voilà le
4-1 vous le ferez pendant la pub alors
voilà on va passer on va reparler que
frédéric koller puisqu'on va parler
notamment de voice dont il va revenir ce
bateau rester calme venez vous asseoir
frédéric à tout à l'heure mais selon
votre couple préféré
bref un petit sondage ah bah oui
francesca mathieu 51% oui quand même
maxime magali se passe quelque chose
c'est correct on est des fous du roi
c'est étrange quand même nom 12% sais
pas c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
terrible s'agira pas mal ban en est loin
et xenia bon c'était déjà pas mal 12%
daniel parce que franchement tous
pourtant j'aurais pas j'aurais pas parié
une tonne d'argent monsieur quand même